I've been going through the cinemasins
fan mail a little bit I don't know if
you ever read any of those no I mean I
see a select group of fan mail I
filtered by keywords so that I don't
have to look at all of it he and what
are the keywords attractive handsome
awesome hot sex hot sex awesome hot sex
free beer okay so you definitely don't
know that there's a lot of people who
won't need to do sins of other content
no I think it's 25% of your audience is
asking you to do sins of stuff besides
just movies like what do they want me to
do like sins of video games is a popular
suggestion I don't really play video
campus you used to well yeah but that
was years ago like is pitfall still
popular no but that's sort of my point
like you guys you're not a complete
newbie when it comes to video games but
in played in a while
so you bring in no bias no preconceived
notions no playing favorites I think it
might be a good idea but how would I
even do sins of video games like the
experience is different for each play I
mean like grand theft auto like don't
some people play the story mode instead
of just killing hookers and sniping
people I think yeah like imagine yeah so
wouldn't they rather see sins of like
the story mode rather than the ones I
would write should be like you know this
hooker didn't have enough money on her
after I killed her in the sucker didn't
blow me ding I think they would probably
expect you to play the story mode yeah
but I guess I get your point you you
couldn't really call it everything wrong
with because everybody's experience is a
little different so it's more your
experience of what's wrong with it if
you call it some of the things wrong
what else you got rooms all right
sends up TV shows mmm pass wand do you
realize how many episodes successful TV
shows have like 50 or 100 hours content
to comb through and find sins I'm going
to lazy for that maybe the sins don't
have to be so specific with TV maybe
it's instead of continuity errors and
little tiny and discrepancies from one
shot to another you pull out and do more
of a broad view like if it was lost you
can do all the sins for the mysteries
that they never explained or you could
do a bonus round of Jack speeches or
something what else you got
all right let's see sins of movie
trailers 99% up and give away the movie
there anything else bad sins of board
games this game has too many shoots and
not enough ladders sting sins of books
reading ding music videos how about
music video sentence know that they
exist there's not enough nudity in them
since of comic books is one that I see a
lot well no how is that supposed to work
genius just to rip out all the pages and
scan them so I can get them on the
computer and I don't know I'm just the
messenger here alright this is what the
fans are saying about the fans and
sometimes stoop them sure they'll be
happy to hear that about sins of YouTube
channels isn't that what the comments
section is for we got to pick one of
them oh god I do anything okay
I'll rephrase you should pick one of
them this is what the fans are telling
you they want to see you'd be really
wise to do one alright I guess I'm doing
video games okay cuz then these could
play video games again
which I have been able to do since you
got married and your wife put the kibosh
on my xbox be nice to her game thought
it was mine and I'm sorry all right now
let me make it up to you don't that's
possible oh look I got you gift great a
box not just any box it's a PlayStation
3 box why did you get me a PlayStation 3
box because there's a PlayStation 3
right because that's what we do we spend
hundreds of dollars on each other
lavish unnecessary gift no con man I
promise I thought you might want to do
sins of video games or something
something similar Simba sins let's play
a video or something I got you a
PlayStation 3 yeah I'm sure you didn't
want it you don't have to keep it I'm
not gonna keep an empty box dude does a
good PlayStation in there alright those
not if there was a real playstation in
here would I do this apparently yes that
was real wasn't it yeah like only told
you like five times before you threw it
across the room you got a spare though
right